do we understand the young man that died
that would take responsibility for the
departure
okay
look this is out because all I heard was
that you just need to know that I am
with God I don't care if you believe in
nothing else I need you to have the
faith in knowing
that he is working so hard
to let you know that he's okay
and he does not want you to carry this
burden or feeling that you could have or
should have been able to have prevented
the departure do you understand that
yes and I feel like did you actually
have a dream of him
I've had a few okay I don't dream of my
loved ones that have died so because he
goes I don't even know why he's worried
about me I showed him in a dream that I
was fine
so know that what you experienced was a
visitation know that that was his soul
showing himself to you to give you the
gift and saying please do not let how I
die Define who I was
do you understand that don't be afraid
to talk about him do you understand that
because you're so afraid
I am okay I Want You In This Moment sir
to please share me something about him
because I want you to leave me and
everyone in this audience today with the
gift of a beautiful memory of him not of
that he passed tragically anything he
did would make you laugh anything
he never had to try it was effortless he
could do the most normal thing and it
wouldn't be funny if anyone else did it
but it was extra funny if he did it he
literally just said to me kind of like
The Three Stooges Theresa you know like
when you watch The Three Stooges he goes
that's how we were anyway right yes
exactly why does he keep showing me
these necklaces do you have a necklace
in memory of him or for him
we have several necklaces made with his
Cremations
and is it engraved or is it his thumb
print in it or why does he even show me
a print did he serve all country or
police officer or fireman because he's
saluting you
I'm a police officer oh you're a police
officer perfect so validating that his
soul is at peace with God thanking you
for your service and knowing how he was
laid to rest because I keep seeing
things being being released in memory of
him
did you like the song Amazing Grace
like your mom
singing me Amazing Grace I said you're
distracting me I'm trying to talk to
this
she goes but I love this this song
she was your mom very ill prior to her
departure because she says look at how
good I look and she made my whole body
usually spirit will just like make my
life I'm not done with him yet we're
just giving we're giving him a little
we're giving him a little break because
I don't know if he can like this is
where we need the um where the levity
comes in do you understand that and what
you usually a soul will make my legs
feel numb and then jump up and down
validating that they don't they didn't
take any disability or ailment with them
on the other side literally your mom and
I've never had this I'm doing this
decades and I love to share when Souls
show me something that I've never had
before because it validates the strength
of their soul like my whole body went
numb and then she started dancing so
validating that she took nothing with
her did she have something with her
eyesight because she goes oh she goes I
didn't realize how beaut it was almost
like she took me in The Wizard of Oz
like when Dorothy goes from black and
white to Oz where it's all color that's
what she made me feel like she's like is
this really what the world looked like
so know that she does and not even the
disability with her eyes know that any
disability she left with the physical
body did you care for your mom because
she shows me you she goes do you know my
daughter she's not even a nurse and the
way that she cared for me a daughter
should not have to do that for a mom but
I want to thank you for allowing me to
leave the physical world with dignity
and Grace and you're always making me
sure that I was fixed and everything I
always looked nice she goes you know she
always changed my nightgown every single
day
validating thanking you for all those
little things that you did for her
and she says and you still can't believe
that she's gone no no so know that when
you have that feeling and that
loneliness and you feel like I can't
know in that moment that she's with you
your mom shows me her your mom is very
funny she goes ask her ask her Teresa
would that be your mom the way she would
be ask her she goes she kept all my
recipes but God forbid she make anything
from the recipe book
laughs
[Music]